are most of the top Grapplers on
steroids I mean it's hard to say you
know some people look like [__] and
they're on steroids some people look
excellent and they're not upstairs it's
so so hard to tell but that seems to be
the the general consensus that a lot of
people on steroids I'm always a little
bit I don't know I'll be honest I've
never
I've never seen anyone take steroids
I've never taken steroids I don't even
know the story term to use or like trt
any of that so I'm very careful like to
not let my naive fatay like
um lead me to take conclusions but I do
feel a little bit weird about the Witch
Hunt nature of it that some people a
little bit too eagerly claim that others
are on steroids just because they're
successful
um but at the same time it does seem
that a lot of athletes will do whatever
it takes to be successful yeah I mean if
it's well it doesn't test you got to
assume most people are gonna do it and
especially now as more money comes into
the sport you've got to assure more
people are going to do it you know I
generally like do agcc and like the
suggested test it's actually encouraged
what's encouraging okay
you get a pamphlet okay they don't test
there's no testing they test to make
sure we're on steroids because obviously
it's a big show for the UFC fight Plus
in the future you don't want anyone
coming in out of shape very nice do you
think using steroids in that kind of
context and sports is wrong like
stepping stepping away if it's not
illegal I mean do you think ethically
speaking I like to stream everyone's on
stairs and I have to feel bad about
using stairs myself yeah
do you use them you use all of the
steroids I'm over 30 it's TRD you know
that's a medical definition
that's the medical okay
uh I'd like to meet your dog therapeutic
use you know therapeutic right
um like how do you just feel about it I
mean it is cheating for sure whether
they test for it or not I think it is
cheating obviously some people are going
to say oh [__] everyone's on it uh I
should be able to get away with it it
makes it even playing field you know but
it kind of becomes Rush from roulette
because it's like if one guy's taking a
small amount and the other guy is taking
a huge amount he's gonna reap huge
rewards in the short term probably be
dead pretty early but die a champion
mind you you know what I mean so it's
like I don't know what that one is yeah
yeah what do you think about that do you
think do you think it's worthy to take
health risks I think if you're just for
the glory I think if you're 40 about to
die looking at a cabinet of gold medals
for wrestling other men it's probably
not going to hit the same way on your
deathbatch you know what sorry in which
direction
like is that a good thing or not no
probably you're probably gonna feel like
oh [__] I probably wasted a bit of
Health on that you know you think so
isn't that isn't that like the glory of
it
like you said other men yeah yeah yeah
yeah well I mean like you know maybe
wrestle a woman as well but
what'd you do with with Gabby on
Valentine's Day what did you take her we
filmed some new stuff for early fans for
only fans we never stopped working
this is the love affair is also a work
Affair okay I don't know I I
there's something too that made like
like Olympic gold medalists
accomplishing like the heights is
sacrificing everything just everything
the first 20 30 years of your life for
this silly little piece of metal I don't
I think there's something beautiful to
that that's like inspires a lot a lot of
people and that's like
the height of the human condition in a
way like why don't you survive I'm just
saying if you're in your deathbed early
in life we all die all men die but not
all men truly live
how many years are you willing to shave
off for a gold medal that's a good
question how many how many are you
willing to shave off for a gold medal
well you're for silver medal for silver
I mean for silver metal I just have a
few off I think two Silvers makes a gold
it's worth five years
five to ten maybe yeah
shove off the bad news and haunts the
good ones you know well I mean you've
sacrificed you guys sacrificed a lot a
lot of your life you continue to
sacrifice oh you don't see the sacrifice
it's fun I think training's fun being
adamant about it consistent gives you I
mean we I think we have a great routine
great ritual definitely enjoy the
process
all right well do you guys know this is
Bro Science or or I'm talking bro
scientists but do you know how long
steroids stay in your system
forever forever oh because hey once you
do it you own it yeah
just the knowledge yeah all right I
think it's I think it's different for
each steroid right I think some of them
last longer than others depends if it's
a urine you would think I would do a
little research before this asking these
questions why do you think most athletes
and coaches don't talk about steroids
like why is it such a like a secret why
is it so embarrassing I think they
probably talk about it like amongst the
team and whatnot again I mean it's only
it's going to be more shady if it's like
a your your sport is tested or not we're
kind of in the Wild West in the in the
grappling world you know yeah but why
don't Grapplers talk about it
because it seems cheating I mean it's
it's kind of insinuated as a bit of
cheating even if it's not like uh if
it's not tested I mean still you're
you're taking a person that could you
know maybe has good Jiu Jitsu good
mechanics you're putting them on the leg
and they're subbing you with a hill hook
versus breaking your leg with a yolk you
know something a subtle as that can make
you know big differences all right this
is gonna make me sound dumb but is it
possible that steroids are not a huge
help in grappling
I think if you're bad at Jiu Jitsu and
you do steroids you're going to continue
to be bad at Jutsu but if you're great
at gear I'm sorry if you're great at
grappling if you're great at grappling
and then you also do gear it's going to
enhance what you're already you know
good at and make you much better but
like how much is the enhancement I guess
is the question how much is is muscle
valued right like if you're a question
if you're doing gear and you're not
changing weight that much like maybe it
helps you a little bit but if you know
you're gaining 50 60 pounds of pure
muscle and it's like that's a huge
enhancement that's another human this
this this muscle a small human yeah uh
does does muscle matter in Jiu Jitsu I
guess is the question is it possible
that it gets in the way I say muscle
matters but technique matters more I
also think that it it'll help you
develop technique as well because
obviously you know testosterone helps
with recovery rate so if you're on gear
you're able to train a lot more now that
being said if you're not able to learn
obviously it's not going to help in that
aspect but if you're somebody that knows
how to learn and get good at Jiu Jitsu
and then you add gear on top of that
you're able to do significantly more
sessions throughout the week okay and by
the way gears there was steroids yeah
I also think that you don't have to be
as consistent uh in like your sleep and
your food and stuff if you're if your
own gear you have a little bit of leeway
um but I mean being consistent in your
diet and your sleep definitely would
would help you know the process since
you use most steroids of any athlete
I've ever met do you think
steroidsu oh man I think obviously it
helps recovery in your ability to train
well but I think some I've seen some
guys go on steroids and then suddenly
they feel like the Incredible Hulk and
now in the training room they just start
to rely more on strength than the
techniques they had and actually in some
respect Hinduism and make some gas more
in competition because then they're
using more of the muscle they never used
to have so
you've implied that you're a natural
athlete
you said that you said that skeptically
is this something you do for it for
social media to talk [__] to Gordon to
imply he's not a natural athlete well I
only uh pretty much recently on social
media had this rebuttal you know saying
that you know Gordon's on gear and I
only said that because after after our
match in in the our most recent match
you know the ebi rules match he accused
me of greasing which is like lubing up
so I'm slippery during our match so and
you did not I did not I was checked
multiple times before and after uh our
grappling event and uh he still you know
went out and accused me of this so I was
like all right as opposed to telling a
lie I'll just tell the truth about you
know your steroid use which it shouldn't
be that big of a deal in retrospect
because he kind of admitted it and
whatnot you know previously
um so it's uh yeah I just kind of felt
like I had to rebuttal and I I didn't do
it immediately because I was like all
right I know I have this podcast planned
so I'll wait to do it on you know my
friend uh Mark Bells podcast you know it
could be a little more more get a little
bit more exposure on it and uh yeah I
knew he was gonna bite the baby I didn't
think it was gonna you know bite the
baby that hard I I know he's a little
stressed out about about the comment but
you know and that was the origin of you
guys going back and forth on well it
wasn't so much back and forth it was
just I went forth and then he kept going
back back like I remember one of one of
my guys DM me and they were like
Gordon's made like 68 Instagram stories
and 67 of them were all about you I was
like all right well I'm in his head for
sure got us a few followers we
appreciate it we did we did followers he
even shouted out or RB team Wipeout
program so thank you yeah
uh